in the last video we hopefully got the
intuition between how real interest
rates might impact planned investment we
saw that if real interest rates went up
then planned investment planned
investment went down if real interest
rates went down then planned investment
planned investment went up what we want
to do in this video is take this
conclusion right over here this
hopefully fairly intuitive conclusion
right over here and apply it to our
keynesian cross and think about how real
interest rates would affect overall
planned expenditure and then what that
would do in a model like the keynesian
cross what that would do to our
equilibrium g real gdp
so just as a reminder so let's just draw
our keynesian cross first or parts of it
so on this axis right over here we have
expenditures
expenditures this axis right over here
we have income and we know for many
videos now that an economy is in
equilibrium when income is equal when
aggregate income aggregate real income
is equal to aggregate real expenditures
circular flow of gdp
so let's draw let me make a line that's
all the points where y is equal to
expenditures
so along this 45 degree line right over
here so this is our expenditures at this
point right over here that should be the
same value as what our aggregate income
is now that's part of the keynesian
cross the other part is to actually plot
planned expenditures relative to this
and then see where they intersect what
is the equilibrium point on that planned
expenditure line and i'll write it here
as i've written it in the past as
planned i just wrote out the word
planned
planned expenditures we could write it
even as we could write it as
it as expenditures planned like that and
it's equal to
it's equal to our aggregate consumption
and our aggregate consumption we can
write it as a function of disposable
income y minus t is disposable income
aggregate income minus aggregate taxes
and i want to be very clear here this is
not saying c times y minus t this is
saying c is a function of y minus t give
me a y minus t and i will give you a c
and for the sake of our keynesian cross
analysis and this is kind of what you
would see in a traditional intro class
we assume that we have a linear
consumption function so we assume that
our consumption function so c as a
function of disposable incumbent might
be something like our autonomous
consumption plus our marginal propensity
to consume times our aggregate income
minus taxes so this right over here
really is multiplication we could really
distribute the c1 this is just saying c
as a function of y minus t
so that's only one part of planned
expenditures above and beyond that we
have investment planned investment we're
talking about the plan side of things
and now we know that planned investment
in the past we've viewed it as we viewed
it as a constant but now we know it can
actually be a function a function of
real interest rates and then above and
beyond that we have government
expenditures and then net exports so for
some given real interest rate we can
plot this line the consumption function
right over here is just a is just a line
with a positive slope that intersects
the y the vertical axis it's someplace
up here some has a positive intercept
and so all of these for given interest
rate these are all going to be constant
and so our planned expenditures would
look something like this
so it might look something
like that so this is
y
p
let's call this yp underscore 1 and this
is the yp we get when we pick and i'll
just write so i'll just rewrite the
whole thing over again so we have our
consumption which is a function of y
minus t
plus
the level of planned investment at let's
say interest rate r1 so at some at some
given interest rate plus government
spending plus
net plus net exports and we see we've
done this keynesian cross analysis
several times now already this is our
equal equilibrium level of gdp this is
where along our planned expenditure line
where income is equal to expenditures
where output is equal to expenditures we
have a balanced we are at equilibrium
right over here we aren't having
unplanned we're not eating into
inventories in an unplanned way and
we're not building excessive inventories
above and beyond what we had planned
now what i want to think about what
happens if interest rates what happens
if interest rates go from r1 to r2
so what happens if interest rates go
from r1 to r2 and in particular in
particular let's assume that r2 so now
we're going to have planned investment
at r2 and we're going to assume that r2
is less than r1 so we're essentially
saying what happens when interest rates
go down well we already know when
interest rates go down planned
investment planned investment goes up so
all everything else equal if this thing
shifts up if this term right over here
goes from r if the input into it if the
real interest rate goes down then this
whole expression is going to go up and
so you're going to have an increase
you're going to have a shifting up of
your planned expenditures for any level
of income and so it might look something
like this
it would look something like this so
this delta right over here
this let me do it right over here so
this distance right over here is going
to be your change in planned investment
and it went up because interest rates
went down we saw that in the last video
and we saw that we got to a new level or
we see now that when you shift that up
that investment goes up because real
interest rate went down you get to a new
equilibrium point and that equilibrium
point is a higher level it's a higher
level of gdp or income and we know from
previous videos as well that this
distance right over here is the same as
our multiplier times the amount that
things got bumped up so the amount that
things got bumped up was
the change in planned investment and
then we'd multiply that times our
multiplier and our multiplier is one
over the marginal propensity to save or
one over one minus the marginal
propensity to consume and the marginal
propensity to consume if we assume and
we assume it's going to be constant in
order to even be able to do this math
that's this piece right over there so
that is equal to our c1
but the main theme here the real big
picture here is we as we go on our way
to constructing our islm model is really
that all we're seeing look interest
rates when real interest rates go up
plan investment goes down when interest
rates go down which is what we saw in
this example right over here so actually
let me write this down so y
so planned expenditures 2 it's c
as a function of y minus t plus our new
planned investment at this lower
interest rate plus g
plus net exports this is our y2 right
over here our planned expenditures so we
saw in this example when real interest
rates went down plan expenditures
when real interest rates went down
planned investment went up and that made
planned that made total planned
expenditures go up and that may total
gdp go up so now we can have a another
relationship which is really very
analogous to this because really by
changing this we're just shifting this
curve and then you have the multiplier
effect on our equilibrium output so the
big takeaway from here is if real
interest rates go up not only does
planned investment go down that would
shift this entire curve down and then
that would also cause our equilibrium
real gdp
to go down and it would go down by some
multiplier by the multiplier of how much
this goes down if real interest rates go
down then planned investment because of
what we saw in the last video goes up
and then that would cause that would
cause this whole that's what we did in
this video this curve would shift up and
if this curve shifts up our equilibrium
gdp is going to be however much of this
shifted times the multiplier and so your
equilibrium gdp is going to go up so you
really have a very similar relationship
in terms of just how things move and we
can plan we can plot this
and economists are famous for not always
plotting the independent variable to
where you would want to
so as we construct our what we're going
to see is our is curve and it stands for
investment savings what we're going to
do and we'll talk more about that in the
future we plot the convention is to put
real interest rates on the vertical axis
and to put
and to put real gdp right over here and
so if you want to look at this
relationship when we have a high real
interest rate we're going to have a low
real gdp and when we have a low real
interest rate we're going to have a high
gdp because it helps it's going to make
spending go up spending goes up you have
a multiplier effect makes our
equilibrium output go up so low interest
rates high real gdp and so you have a
curve that relates if you want to relate
real gdp to real interest rates you get
a curve like this and it's called the is
curve and is comes for investment
savings but we're really more focused on
the i part of it the way we analyzed
here because the whole reason based on
the logic in this video and the last one
as well the whole reason why we have
this relationship is due to real
interest rates impact on investment when
you have higher real interest rates you
don't have much investment and that also
you also will you'll be sapping out of
gdp
if you lower interest rates then that
makes you get end up having a lot more
investment like we saw in the last video
and that will expand gdp by the
multiplier that we see right over there